apporte responsables du collectif
cheminée au parti communiste français
nous a rejoint sur ce plateau thomas
porte bonjour genre merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation des ruptures rc
france alors le premier ministre a donc
profité du conseil des ministres
exceptionnel consacré aux coronavirus ce
samedi pour annoncer le recours aux 49 3
votre réaction
je crois que c'est totalement
insupportable puisque vous l'avais dit
c'était un conseil des ministres qui
étaient destinés à parer à la crise
sanitaire que traverse le pays et on a
empreint samedi après midi à 17h en
catimini qu'on utilise le 49-3 dans une
situation où ce pays n'accepte pas la
réforme le conseil d'état contre la
réforme deux tiers des français sont
contre la réforme l'ensemble des
syndicats sont contre la réforme le
gouvernement qui a pourtant une majorité
à l'assemblée nationale utilise le
processus le plus anti démocratique
existe je crois et pour un gouvernement
qui se dit le nouveau monde utilisé un
article absolument marquer que c'est pas
acceptable c'est un véritable bras
d'honneur à ce pays
c'est un piétinement de la démocratie et
je crois que la colère elle s'exprimait
immédiatement le soir même avec une
mobilisation devant l'assemblée hier on
a vu la comédie française et je crois
que ça c'était pas calmé la colère ça a
pris d'autres formes de mobilisation et
je crois que ça va repartir dans les
jours à venir parce que les français
n'acceptent pas un passage en force sur
un sujet aussi sensible qui n'a pas de
majorité dans ce pays alors la
mobilisation ne revient dans un instant
mais avant est ce que finalement
l'opposition c'est un peu tiré une balle
dans le pied avec ses milliers
d'amendements qui avait été déposé froch
l'opposition elle utilise les moyens qui
sont à sa disposition c'est à dire
amender un texte et un projet de loi est
aujourd'hui faire peser la
responsabilité du 49-3 sur l'opposition
c'est un peu gros je crois que personne
n'est dupe on s'y attendait depuis des
jours à voir se tait ce texte passé en
49 3 parce que le gouvernement avait dit
qu'il voulait qu'il soit mis en place
avant les municipales
mais j'aimerais bien qu'on nous explique
aujourd'hui quel est le lien entre le
projet de réforme des retraites et la
question des élections municipales
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous on
avait posé en tout cas les députés
communistes les soumis des
questions de fond sur ce texte là on
n'avait aucune réponse et le
gouvernement était en difficulté et en
même temps s'ils tombent le samedi ne
tombe pas totalement au hasard non plus
le 49-3 c'est avant l'utilisation
enfin le débat sur certains articles
notamment la question de l'âge
déquilibre la question du poids du
financement du point où le gouvernement
je le répète est dans l'incapacité de
répondre est dans l'incapacité de dire
aux français ce que va améliorer cette
réforme a le quotidien
donc ils ont préféré passer en force
qu'on ne pas répondre aux questions de
l'opposition
c'est regrettable ni roman on a pu
observer en ces derniers jours un climat
délétère au sein au coeur de l'assemblée
nationale est ce que les débats
pouvaient avoir lieu dans ce contexte là
dans ces temples de cette atmosphère la
roque effectivement il y avait une
atmosphère tendue à la fin mai nationale
mais c'est parce qu'on était sur un
débat de fond et sur un débat qui mérite
de prendre du temps d'avoir des
discutions de la concertation est
aujourd'hui la république en marche n'a
pas fait ce choix là depuis le début
tout ce qu'on a eu une preuve processus
accéléré un semblant de concertation
avec les organisations syndicales un
semblant de débat avec les
parlementaires et au voc depuis le début
c'était l'approximation et le mépris qui
règne parce qu'on est passé quand même
il faut le rappeler du ministre de des
retraites qui avait oublié de déclarer
ses revenus du rapporteur de la loi qui
avait des actions chez axa et
aujourd'hui on refuse le débat à
l'assemblée
c'est totalement surréaliste pour un
sujet qui va bouleverser quand même le
quotidien de millions de français dans
les années à venir
l'utilisation ce 49,3 ne signifie pas
pour autant l'adoption définitive on
peut le rappeler du texte ni la fin du
parcours législatif de la réforme des
retraites
est-ce que l'exécutif peut encore faire
marche arrière
je crois qu'il peut toujours faire
marche arrière on a coutume de dire que
tant qu'un projet de loi n'est pas
adoptée on peut le retirer
c'est ce qu'on demande depuis des
semaines est d'ailleurs le dernier
sondage d'opinion qui a été fait montre
que 70% des français quasiment veulent
être consultés par référendum sur ce
texte là donc si le gouvernement est si
attaché que c'est la démocratie qui
consultaient les français qui sont en
capacité aujourd'hui de comprendre ce
que va apporter cette réforme des
retraites et qu'il mette un référendum
sur cette question là c'est ce que les
parlementaires communistes ont réclamé
il ya une grande pétition nationale qui
a circulé lancé pour l'aréna l'humanité
consulter les français par référendum
demandé leur avis et après on verra
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas c'est
vraiment dommage alors les députés et de
droite et de gauche on lisait donc parti
socialiste ont déposé deux motions de
censure contre le gouvernement
cela va avoir un impact sur vous
évidemment on connaît aujourd'hui la
représentativité à l'assemblée nationale
notre reportage l'a rappelé la majorité
absolue est encore entre les mains de la
république en marche mais je crois que
c'est de la responsabilité des
parlementaires dans ces situations là
nous déposer une motion de censure pour
dire qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas
d'accord avec ce processus là mais je
crois qu'il ya aussi des échéances
électorales qui approche et on peut
aussi déposer
motion de censure électorale à l'égard
de toutes celles et ceux qui
représentent la république en marche
dans ce pays il faut voter pour des
majorités de gauche on a besoin d'avoir
une autre société à notre projet de
société
je crois qu'il faut avoir des élus qui
combattent ces politiques régressives et
les élections municipales sont un bon
moyen d'envoyer un signal clair à
l'arrêt plus qu'en mars alors le premier
ministre edouard philippe adressé une
lettre aux syndicats pour leur expliquer
ce fameux recours 49,3 et ce qu'il
advenait de la conférence sur le
financement des futurs retraite qu'est
ce que vous en retenez qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
je crois que c'est on a l'habitude des
décors et d'edouard philippe qui les
envoie juste au moment où il prend des
décisions donc c'est pas de la réelle
information c'est une opération de
communication
la conférence de financement n'a pour le
moment débouché sur rien et même les
organisations syndicales et notamment la
cfdt qui était favorable à cette
conférence de financement 10 partout
qu'il n'y a pas d'avancée donc je crois
que c'est encore une fois un jeu de
dupes qui est menée
la seule réponse qu'on peut apporter à
ce gouvernement aussi bien sur le 49-3
que sur toutes décisions qui sont prises
c'est une mobilisation massive
on a vu déjà que ça a commencé dans
certains secteurs et je crois que dans
d'autres secteurs où on est soumis à des
déclarations de droit de grève qui sont
de 48 heures ça va repartir dans les
jours à venir c'est une certitude ce que
je peux vous assurer que cette décision
elle a été très mal accueillie par la
salariée du pays alors justement vous
lisiez mobilisation qui se prépare
aujourd'hui des syndicats des
organisations se retrouvent pour parler
de l'avenir à quoi est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir s'attendre selon vous je crois
qu'il ya déjà une mobilisation qui va
avoir lieu demain jour du dépôt des
motions de censure à l'égard du
gouvernement et une journée d'action
était prévu déjà le 31 mars mais je
crois qu'il aura d'autres journées
d'action et notamment la semaine
prochaine qui se prépare comme je lé
rappeler certains secteurs sont soumis à
un dépôt de déclarations de grève de 48
heures mais croyez moi à toutes celles
et ceux qui ont été mobilisés pendant
plus de 50 jours
ils vont pas repartir au travail comme
si de rien n'était et je crois que cette
nouvelle provocation elle n'est pas de
nature à calmer la colère populaire mais
au contraire d'augmenter et a prouvé une
fois de plus que nous avions raison dès
le départ que ce gouvernement ne veut
pas discuter et son seul objectif c'est
de passer une réforme impopulaire qui
répondent aux desiderata de certaines
personnes et sûrement pas l'intérêt
général pour conclure les rassemblements
de plus de cinq mille personnes sont
interdits aujourd'hui à cause de la
crise du corona virus
vous adapter on va s'adapter
effectivement on est bien conscients
aussi de ces soucis-là de santé publique
qui sont en train de s'inscrire dans le
paysage du pays mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui à d'autres formes de
mobilisation
iliad il ya d'autres formes d'action
possible mais c'est quand même assez
curieux quand même je le répète de
passer à 49,3 à l'issue d'un conseil des
ministres qui étaient dédiés à la crise
du gros navires us
ça montre quand même tout le mépris pour
les mobilisations dans ce pays merci
beaucoup thomas port d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
responsable du collectif cheminots au
parti communiste français
merci